the Muller saga finally ends but will it
ever really end plus the wild story of a
Harvard Law Professor a lesbian con
artist and a transgender roommate it's
not really a joke I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show lot to get to
today so let's jump right in before we
get to the aftermath of the robert
muller hearing yesterday which was
basically a disaster for Democrats and
the way you could tell it was a disaster
for Democrats as folks in the media
insisting that it definitely was not a
disaster for Democrats
they weren't suggesting it was a win but
it definitely wasn't as big a disaster
as everybody saying yeah it kind of was
we'll get to that in just a second first
Jeffrey Epstein is now on suicide watch
after he was found with neck injuries in
jail this of course since Clinton body
counts trending ontwitter
because that's always how this works
whenever somebody close to the Clintons
dies everybody on the right immediately
assumes the Clintons did it because
everyone is a little crazy in any case
the New York Post reports convicted
pedophile Jeffrey Epstein has been
placed on suicide watch after being
found sprawled out and injured in his
federal jail cell law enforcement
sources said Thursday Epstein was nearly
unconscious in his cell Tuesday at
Manhattan's Metropolitan Correctional
Center with injuries to his neck he is
of course being held at the jail without
bail pending trial on child sex
trafficking at charges
who's rushed into a nearby hospital by
Thursday he was back at the jail and the
unsuited to sources investigators say
that they don't think that this was him
being attacked they instead think that
he may have injured himself on purpose
or as a ploy so that he'd get
transferred out of jail because he
doesn't like the conditions over there
of course he is facing up to 45 years in
prison we will look for more information
as it comes out but so far all we know
is that Jeffrey Epstein is one of the
world's worst human beings and because
we know that he is one of the world's
worst human beings it is highly doubtful
that he was actually attempting to
commit suicide and given the conditions
of the jail it's pretty doubtful that
somebody tried to injure him while he
was in the jail I mean he is one of the
most highly publicized people in
American public life at this point okay
now to the fallout from NEMA law hearing
yesterday well if you missed the Muller
hearing yesterday there were no
fireworks
it was a fizzle it was a a lot of
build-up and no payoff a lot of foreplay
and no
if it was really not good for Democrats
because the whole thing was built up as
an optic routine it was not built up as
a Content thing it was not all about the
content that Muller was going to provide
instead it was just going to be solid
man of the law sits there and tells you
all the ways that Donald Trump is bad
that's not how it turned out it turned
out that mother looked uncertain it
turned out he didn't know his own report
particularly well it turned out that
every time he gave the Democrats a win
with one of his lines he immediately
pulled back from that win and this was a
mistake for Democrats it was a big
mistake for Democrats there's a lot of
talk early on Jerry Nadler I remember
very early after the Mullen report was
released 448 page report you can read
the whole thing it's not non-public
after that came out Jerry Nadler
suggested maybe we won't call my lawyer
to testify and I was wondering out loud
at the time why would he not
maybe it's because Muller just wouldn't
be that good witness maybe it's because
Muller is not gonna say anything more
than he already said in the report but
due to external pressure due to the fact
that there are so many people dreaming
of the day when Donald Trump would be
frog-marched out of the White House by
robert muller and his 73 year old
six-pack all the crafts enstein brothers
who were patting themselves on the back
getting the massage oils ready none of
this was real but Democrats decided to
go for it anyway and it really backfired
on them in a fairly significant way if
they wanted to push forward with
impeachment they should not have had my
or testify they should have just taken
his report they should have said listen
the report provides us the evidence that
we need to begin impeachment proceedings
the president can't be prosecuted
because of the OLC the office of legal
counsel ruling that sitting presidents
can't be prosecuted but we are here to
make sure that no one is above the law
my Democrats could have done that Nancy
Pelosi didn't want to because it's
pretty unpopular and most Democrats
weren't gonna vote for it in fact they
held an impeachment vote basically a
week ago and only 95 Democrats voted in
favor a majority of Democrats voted
against Oh impeachment is basically DOA
they were hoping to breathe some life
back into it what the Muller hearing
that is not what happened we'll go
through it in just one second and then
we'll get to the insane fallout from the
Muller hearing and the spin the media
are trying to put upon it
first I am always concerned about cyber
security and public figure I'm on the
internet nearly 24 hours a day whether
I'm at home or abroad but when you're
abroad you also have to worry about not
being able to visit the sites that you
want because there may
crackdowns on those sites when you're at
home you have people who are trying to
steal your data well there is one app
that's gonna keep you safe and secure
online whether your home or a way that
is expressed at VPN expressvpn runs in
the background of your computer or phone
then you just use the internet the way
you normally would you download the app
you click to connect and voila you are
now protected
I never go online with it while
traveling without expressvpn also I
won't do it even when I'm in the United
States you shouldn't either Express VPN
is the fastest VPN I've tried it cost
less than seven bucks per month it comes
with a 30-day money-back guarantee
expressvpn uses new cutting-edge
technology called trusted server to make
sure there are no logs of what you
actually do online so no matter what
you're trying to browse online Express
VPN gives you instant access all over
the world and protects you from people
trying to take your data from you
without your permission protect your
online activity today find out how you
can get 3 months for free and expressvpn
calm / Ben that's expr ESS VPN com /
been for 3 months free with 1-year
package that's expressive VPN calm / Ben
to learn more ok so let's recap what
exactly robert muller said yesterday so
robert muller gave a couple of moments
to the democrats but none of them were
particularly telling so moment number
one he said that he did not totally
exonerate from now no one who actually
read the report or followed the media
coverage thought trump was totally
exonerated on the question of
obstruction nobody thought that in fact
there were poles of Americans and
Americans were asked do you think Trump
is exonerated and a majority of
Americans said no so Muller is rebutting
a point that nobody actually believed in
the first place Democrats were touting
this well look at that
stinging rebuke to trump wait a second
you're telling me that President Trump
mischaracterizes what other people say
sometimes no no that can't be true am I
supposed to be shocked by this
here's representative Jerry Nadler who
is spilling out this question as though
it's a revelation the president has
repeatedly claimed that your report
found there was no obstruction and that
it completely and totally exonerated him
but that is not what your report said is
it correct that is not what the report
says so the report did not conclude that
he did not commit obstruction of justice
is that correct that is correct and what
about total exam
raishin did you actually totally
exonerate the president no now in fact
your reports expressly states that it
does not exonerate the president it does
well and then Trump said he was
exonerated boom done impeach yeah we all
know we all know Donald Trump says stuff
that's not true a lot you know like ever
since he's been in American public life
for the last 70 odd years so yeah that's
not that's not gonna do it okay how
about this approach how about Trump
could be charged with obstruction after
he leaves office so now you hear
Democrats trying to trot out the
argument that Donald Trump would be
prosecuted by robert muller after he
leaves office so this is them hoping
against hope and then them saying okay
well if he can't be prosecuted while
he's in office at least he can be
impeached but that's not what Muller is
saying Muller is making a basic
statement of law which is true Trump
could be prosecuted after he leaves
office he cannot be prosecuted while he
is in office that does not mean he
should be prosecuted it's just a
statement of the law the Democrats were
treating this is again another
revelation but it's not a revelation
could you charge the president with a
trim' after he left office yes you
believe that he committed you could
charge the president nine states with
obstruction of justice after he left
office yes well well I'm in case closed
except for the question is not whether
you can charge the president after he
leaves office the question is should you
charge the president after he leaves
office okay then there was an actual
seeming bombshell at the time
Ted Lou was questioning Robert Miller
and he asked him basically the reason
that you didn't prosecute Trump is
because of the OLC opinion right there's
an office of legal counsel opinion from
the Department of Justice that says you
cannot prosecute a sitting president
federally because he's the head of the
federal executive branch and Muller
seems to say that the only reason he
wouldn't prosecute Trump is because of
the OLC opinion right this is this is
the moment the big moment and Democrats
were over the moon about this this was
the headline and all the major websites
at least for about five minutes as we'll
see so here is Robert Miller actually
giving Democrats win was there
sufficient evidence to convict president
Trump or anyone else with obstruction of
justice we could not make that
calculation how could you not have made
the calculation is regular Elsi opinion
feel
the opinion office of legal counsel
indicates that we cannot indict a
sitting president so one of the tools
that a prosecutor would use is not there
you were actually unable to conclude the
president did not commit obstruction of
justice is that correct
well we at the outset determined that
when it came to the the president's
culpability we needed to go forward only
after taking into account the OLC
opinion that indicated that a president
a sitting president cannot be indicted
okay so Democrats jumped on this this
means that if it weren't for the oil C
opinion then Miller would have got him
see they keep trying to make excuses as
to why Muller didn't actually do it
Mellon has told you why he didn't do it
he said he did not even reach the
borderline question of whether Trump
should be prosecuted because the OLC
opinion said he couldn't be prosecuted
so he just didn't even answer the
question so here is Muller walking back
that talking point now he comes back for
his testimony second half of the day and
he then walks back the one win Democrats
have which is the OLC opinion question
now before we go to questions I want to
add one correction to my testimony this
morning I want to go back to one thing
that was said this morning by mr. Lew
who said and I quote you didn't charge
the president because of the OLC opinion
that is not the correct way to say it as
we say in the report and as I said at
the opening we did not reach a
determination as to whether the
president committed a crime
he walks that back to so now Democrats
have nothing and every time they tried
to push Muller into saying that he would
have indicted Trump if it weren't for
the OLC opinion they fail as you'll see
in just one second first let's talk
about credit card debt so if you really
want to make sure that you're behind the
eight ball for life rack up some credit
card debt and then it just let it keep
accruing just let that interest keep
accruing because as you know and maybe
you didn't realize when you signed up
for a credit card if you don't pay off
that credit card like right away they
start charging you like 20 percent a
month and you can immediately be in
serious serious trouble for decades
credit cards have been telling us to buy
it buy it now and then you pay for it
later and they're hoping that you don't
pay for it on time because that's how
they make their money with interest it's
a bad path to follow with Lending Club
you can consolidate your debt or pay off
credit cards with one fixed monthly
payment since
2007 Lending Club has helped millions of
people regain control of their finances
with affordable fixed-rate personal
loans no trips to a bank no high
interest credit cards just go to Lending
Club com tell them about yourself how
much you want to borrow pick the terms
that are right for you if you're
approved your loan is automatically
deposited into your bank accounts in as
little as a few days Lending Club is the
number one peer-to-peer lending platform
over thirty five billion dollars in
loans issued go to Lending Club com /
Bend right now you can check your eight
minutes and borrow up to 40 grand
that's Lending Club com / been Lending
Club calm / ban all loans made by web
bank member FDIC Equal Housing lender
it's pretty easy to get into debt but it
doesn't have to be hard to get out go
check out Lending Club right now Lending
Club com / been use that / ban so that
they know that we say you okay so
another attempt by Democrats - to go
after Trump via Miller and Miller shoots
that one down
so Hakeem Jeffries Democratic Congress
person from New York widely considered
the future of house leadership he tries
to get Muller to basically accede to his
analysis that Trump committed
obstruction of justice he puts up a
chart and then he says here are the
elements of obstruction of justice and
Trump fulfilled all of them
isn't that true sir and Muller is like
not really I'd not gonna say I like
mystery investigation found substantial
evidence that when the president ordered
done began to fire the special counsel
and then lie about it Donald Trump one
committed an obstructive act too
connected to an official proceeding
three did so with corrupt intent those
are the elements of obstruction of
justice this is the United States of
America no one is above the law no one
the president must be held accountable
one way or the other
let me let me just say if I might I
don't subscribe necessarily to your the
way you analyze that I'm not saying it's
out of the ballpark but I'm not
supportive of that analytical charge
ouch ouch
so his green checkmarks of Eila him not
and suddenly there is Robert Muller
shooting him down and this was the story
of the Democrats day what they really
wanted from Muller what they are the
only key headline they wanted from
Muller his mother saying listen I think
that he did criminal stuff and I
prosecute him but you can now the ball
of honesty and truth is in your court
Democrats take it up and run with it
that's what they were hoping for and it
didn't happen any way shape or form
not only that Muller actually provided
some fodder for the other side so
Republican goals when it came to this
particular hearing or twofold goal
number one show that Muller was not
actually in charge of his own
investigation because mother is an
honest guy
but the idea from a lot of Republicans
is that there was some motivation to how
this thing was written it was written in
biased and slanted fashion in order to
provide a supposed roadmap to
impeachment and that maybe Muller wasn't
actually in charge of his own report
that was point number one that
Republicans were trying to make point
number two that they were trying to make
was that the report itself was
fundamentally flawed because it came at
it from the wrong angle the report did
not attempt to convict Trump it
basically said we can't exaggerate
trumple the job of the report was not to
exonerate the person at issue the job of
the report was to provide evidence for
possible prosecution if a prosecution
was on the table but a prosecution
apparently wasn't on the table so what
the hell was this about in the first
place so that was the twofold goal one
Muller wasn't really in charge of the
report to the report itself was
fundamentally flawed and I think there
might have been kind of a third point to
which is that all the talk about Trump
obstructing justice
mama'll or didn't get stopped anywhere
in here right Trump did not step in he's
not curtail Muller's investigation he
did not fire Muller he did not do
anything to hinder or obstruct the
investigation in any real or severe way
he may have jabbered about it to AIDS he
may have suggested to aides that it be
done but it never actually got done so
maybe there were three points those were
the three right Trump did not obstruct
because he didn't stop you robert muller
to you weren't even in charge of this
thing it was all of your democrat
friends and three the the report itself
was fundamentally flawed
so as we'll see in just a second the
republicans were able to make basically
all of these points so on point number
one and point number one was that the
report itself that that the the report
itself did not establish what it sought
to establish with regard to president
Trump namely obstruction because he
didn't curtail or hinder the the actual
investigation and to because the
investigation didn't establish a
conspiracy with Russia's here's Robert
Millar being asked whether his
investigation was curtail or hindered at
any time
the investigation was your investigation
controlled or curtailed or stopped or
hindered no that's a no and a story no
okay and there's a lot of answers like
that from Robert Muller yesterday very
Curt very clipped and then he was asked
did your investigation establish
conspiracy the answer again nope the
investigation did not establish that
members of the Trump campaign conspired
with the Russian government in its
election interference activities okay so
that again goes to the Republicans point
you didn't establish what you're trying
to establish then they get on to point
number two which is you weren't really
in charge of this investigation were you
and Muller appeared hesitant he appeared
tentative he appeared as though he
didn't know his own report as I said
yesterday on the program he appeared
like the kid in your class from third
grade who who was supposed to have done
a book report on Bridge to Terabithia
and didn't actually do the book report
but a parent did and then they came in
and the teacher was like so what
happened in Bridge to Terabithia and the
kid was like well I know there was a
bridge and a place called Terabithia and
there's a lot of that from Robert Miller
so he was asked about fusion GPS now
anyone who has followed this entire
unfolding scandal knows that fusion GPS
is a key player fusion GPS was the group
that went out there and compiled the
steel dossier which may have been
Russian disinformation that was then
funneled upward to Hillary Clinton's law
firm and from there it was funneled to
the FBI and Robert Miller has asked
about fusion GPS and he says he has no
clue what the hell anybody's talking
about when you talk about the the firm
that produced the steel reporting the
name of the firm that produced that was
fusion GPS is that correct I'm not
familiar with that it's not it's not a
trick question I mean it was fusion GPS
now fusion GPS produced the opposition
research document widened widely known
as the steel dossier and the owner of
fuse and GPA was someone named Glenn
Simpson are you familiar with this is
outside my purview okay absolutely not
outside his purview he just doesn't know
his own report it was pretty clear he
didn't know his owner Park and then
there was point number three the
Republicans were trying to establish
which is that the entire
the report is wrong and when Democrats
focus in on Trump being exonerated the
report is designed to provide evidence
sufficient to prosecute or sufficient to
impeach it's not Muller's job to
exonerate Trump it's his job to
prosecute Trump it's not a prosecutor's
job to ever exonerate somebody that
would be the defense attorneys job or
the person's job themselves but it's
really not anybody's job because in the
United States you have to be proved to
have committed a crime
proof of exoneration is not necessary so
here's Muller being asked that question
and admitting he doesn't know of any
other case where the DOJ has
quote-unquote exonerated somebody can
you give me the example other than
Donald Trump where the Justice
Department determined that an
investigated person was not exonerated
because their innocence was not
conclusively determined I cannot but
this is unique okay well you can't
time is short I've got five minutes
let's just leave it it you can't find it
because I'll tell you why it doesn't
exist it was not the special counsels
job to conclusively determine Donald
Trump's innocence or to exonerate him
because the bedrock principle of our
justice system is a presumption of
innocence
it exists for everyone everyone is
entitled to it including sitting
presidents okay so this is a bad day for
Muller he looked bad he looked like he
was stumbling he the optics were bad now
a lot of people in the media us and why
are you looking at the optics because
Democrats explicitly admitted in the
run-up to this this was all for optics
the only reason even have this hearing
was that you could have that image of
Clint Eastwood circa 1971 standing there
growling down the president that's what
they were hoping for from others they
didn't get any of that another like why
are you looking at the optics man well
you just look at the substance well we
already had the substance that's why
we're not looking at the substance
anymore because we all analyzed the
substance I read large swathes of the
report on air no this was about the
optics and the optics did not cut in
favor of the Democrats well president
Trump knew that President Trump reacted
to Mellors testimony with glee and
shortly the Democrats lost so big today
their party is in shambles right now
they've got the squad leading their
party they are a mess this was a
devastating day
for the Democrats this whole thing has
been honestly it's been collusion it's
been collusion with the media it's been
collusion with other countries this has
been a disaster for the Democrats and I
think we're gonna win bigger than ever
okay so you know that is not an unfair
analysis by the president of what the
effect will be although again I don't
know that there will be any effect I
think most people have moved past this
but Democrats won't let go Democrats are
not going to let go of this so you have
Eric's wawel the Congress person from
California who is suggesting guys this
is only the beginning it's only the
beginning now
Eric's wha-whoa as we know knows things
about things that are supposed to begin
and then end quickly and like his
presidential campaign would lasted
approximately thirty seven point two
seconds in which he proposed that we
nuke all gun owners in any case here is
Eric's wawel explaining this is only act
one and this became the Democratic
talking point we're not gonna let go of
this meanwhile Nancy Pelosi in the back
room is saying guys we need to let go of
us here is Eric's wahwah where do where
do we go from here congressman I think
success is that the American people will
view this as volume one or I'm sorry
that the American people will view this
is Act one not Act three and as they
heard names today like manna fort and
Clem Nick and gates they will want to
know well let's hear more about that and
that those witnesses will start to come
forward I think we should have an
impeachment inquiry and those are the
next witnesses we need to hear from no
no I'm pretty sure everybody's like nah
dude not interested and then Adam Schiff
pencil-neck shift according to President
Trump he gets up and he says Muller did
live up to my expectations again this is
a guy who suggested for two years that
he had deep nefarious Intel suggesting
that President Trump was was compromised
here's the Adam Schiff trying to play
this off as a win I do think that Robert
Muller lived up to expectations at least
mine he stuck to his report that's what
he said he was going to do so I didn't
go into the hearing expecting new facts
the halting nature of his answers made
questioning him a challenge you know as
a former prosecutor it meant that you
know you take each witness as they come
and it meant it wasn't easy to get him
to tell a narrative but what's more
important than the style we saw of the
witnesses the substance and the
substance
I think was just devastating okay this
was a dog and pony show everybody knew
as a dog and pony show the dog and pony
show was bad and so it turns to but
don't you love dogs and ponies anyway
hey Adam chef really trying to make a
diamond out of a piece of coal here it's
pretty wild well get to the rest of the
Democratic response in just one second
you can see that everybody is is beside
themselves when you spend two years
building something up and then it turns
out to be a dud it's kind of
disappointing it's like a Pirates of the
Caribbean sequel it'll get to that in
just one second first I am too busy to
go to the post office because and also
last time I went to the post office let
me tell you what happened I drove up to
the post office I stopped outside for
five minutes
the city of Los Angeles sucks at
everything at everything okay this is a
dirty terrible city with horrible local
governance but they are fantastic and
giving parking tickets so I walked
inside
five minutes later I walk out there's a
hundred-dollar parking ticket on my
windshield I am NOT going to the post
office again even though I kind of like
the post office but I can get all their
services by just using stamps calm it is
fast and it is easy
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service
directly to your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices and
online sellers shipping out products
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps comm can handle it
all with ease simply use your computer
to print official US postage 24/7 for
any letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready just hand it to your mail
carrier or drop it in a mailbox it is
indeed that simple with stamps comm you
get five cents off every first-class
stamp up to 40% off Priority Mail not to
mention it is a fraction of the cost of
those expensive postage meters stamps
calm no-brainer saves you time and money
right now my listeners have a special
offer available it includes a four week
trial plus free postage and digital
scale no long term commitments that's a
pretty solid deal go to stamps com click
on that mic at the top of the home page
type in promo code Shapiro for the
special deal that stamps comm enter
Shapiro go check it out
right now okay so the Democrats are sort
of stuck between a rock and a hard place
you spend two years telling your voters
the president Trump will be ridden out
of town on a rail because a Muller mower
shows up and it turns out that he is not
solid it turns out that he is wavering
it turns out that he doesn't know his
own report but Republicans were
basically able to establish that he was
not familiar with his own stuff which
means that it kind of felt like this was
politically motivated and we're about to
find out in the next month whether this
investigation was properly initiated
conducted the Inspector General of the
DOJ Michael Horowitz is about to bring
out a report about the beginnings of the
Trump Russia investigation I'm sure that
will be fascinating stuff his report
certainly on the Hillary investigation
was fascinating reading and pretty
damning for a lot of the folks involved
in all of this
well Democrats are not gonna let go of
this and that includes the people who
are most closely tied to it so Andrew
McCabe who was fired from the FBI for
lying to the FBI
he lost his pension over it and that was
because he lied to the FBI about whether
he had spoken to the press with the
permission of James Comey about Hillary
Clinton's investigation well now Andrew
McCabe is back on television suggesting
it's time for Congress to pursue
impeachment based on what he really
can't explain not based on anything
Muller said that we didn't already know
for sure from my own experience at the
very beginnings of this investigation we
confronted some very hard choices
choices that we knew would have negative
repercussions on our organization and on
us personally and we made those choices
anyway because it was our job and our
duty to do so I feel strongly that
that's the same position Congress is in
now and they should step up to the plate
and do their job it doesn't mean that
the president will be removed from
office or should be removed for off from
office or will be impeached but it is
absolutely clear to me that the time has
come for Congress to pursue a dedicated
impeachment inquiry okay this has become
the talking point people who are very
invested in this thing are not going to
let it go and that's good for Trump
because he can now point to them he can
say listen you petty jerks there's a
full investigation there was no
recommendation of prosecution Muller
himself would not even answer whether he
would prosecute me why in the world are
we still doing this routine if you don't
like me so much you can beat me at the
ballot box by the way Trump is beatable
and for all the talk about the Democrats
being in chaos which is true right now
Trump is underwater in Ohio by four
percentage points according to various
polls including morning consult he's
underwater in Iowa and you know he could
still win those states he's expected to
win those states in fact against a
Democrat right those are just his
popularity ratings still Trump is
vulnerable and yet Democrats don't seem
to want to run against Trump they seem
to want to impeach him or at least talk
about impeaching him for the purposes of
smearing him as a Russian catspaw even
though that all fell apart
the other folks who were invested in
this members of the media deeply
invested CNN every day breaking news
wolf blitzer we have a brand new piece
of news I work out every day
and unfortunately the gym that I attend
very often has CNN on and so I am well
aware of the Chiron's that CNN runs
every single day and the KY runs for two
years were about breaking news bombshell
new report Trump's presidency over the
Russia scandal explodes and then it
turns out that the thing is a complete
waste of time
pretty much and CNN ain't gonna let that
go because it makes them look bad so
here on CNN where folks yesterday trying
to say listen listen listen just because
Bob Muller appeared to be old and
dithering doesn't mean that the
underlying content isn't important guys
you were building this up because you
thought that Bob Muller was gonna walk
in like Tom Cruise in the Top Gun true
trailer and just own it and that is not
the way this worked here is CNN trying
to reverse course quickly back it up
back it up the idea that his written
answers were not truthful is news and
having lived through the Clinton period
where mm you know very much most of what
they focused on was the fact that in a
deposition he wasn't completely honest
and that was enough to impeach him I
think there's going to be as the dust
settles the people who matter was we
talked about yesterday
partisans have made up their mind it's
the people in the middle this was news
to them yesterday and as it sinks in I
think the the Trump people will be a
little more sanguine I don't think the
president will be but this was not a
this was not a win yesterday
no it wasn't it wasn't was it okay
morning Joe they're doing the same
routine Muller gave Democrats everything
that they could possibly need now it's
time for them to move forward it'll be
amazing to see if the Democrats somehow
push their legislators into trying an
impeachment attempt over a report that
did not give them what they wanted good
luck with that guys if you think that's
not gonna backfire on your that people
aren't tired of this I welcome you to
try really go for it do it here is MSNBC
also trying to to play this office of
victory for Democrats well Mickey you
know some people will talk about optics
optics don't really matter here the the
Democrats get all the facts they needed
yeah but the president united states
acted in inappropriately they should
either start an impeachment inquiry
or they should leave it for good but but
you know what if they don't start an
impeachment inquiry given all we learned
yesterday then then obviously nothing
justifies an impeachment inquiry and the
Democrats not starting that inquiry we
will be proving Donald Trump right okay
so Joe Scarborough what he's saying
there is not totally false right he's
been saying you guys need to put your
money where your mouth is but anybody
trying to play this off you can see the
disappointment on Micah's face there
there are a lot of folks in the media
who are very very disappointed among
them Jimmy Kimmel the Pope of late-night
comedy his guy Benson calls him and here
he is being thoroughly unfunny well
going after Republicans for doing what
you would expect Republicans to do
namely Collins a question how exactly
the report was done because there were
serious questions to be asked about the
nature of the report like what was
Robert Mahar doing if he knew he
couldn't prosecute why was this report
not ended with a recommendation one way
or the other
why didn't Robert Miller know his own
report here's Jimmy Kimmel trying to
make excuses I really was something
watching them defend this normally when
people fall on their knees for Trump
like that he pays them a thousand one
hundred thirty thousand dollars
afterwards in hush money but Wow
you know they again you can try this all
night long but in the end you're gonna
run up against the stark reality it was
a bad day for Democrats and this is what
Chris Wallace says so Chris Wallace
somehow ended up on the Stephen Colbert
show last night it didn't go great for
Stephen Colbert so here's Chris Wallace
explaining to Stephen Colbert that
despite Colbert's best hopes and dreams
this thing did not go great this has
been a disaster for the Democrats and a
disaster for the reputation of Robert
Muller now you said that at 10:07 this
morning an hour and a half into a
six-hour series of hearings so is Fox
News motto we report and decide before
the things over
there was a break in the hearing yes you
were asked for our reaction and let me
simply say nothing in your monologue
disproved that description and what way
was it a disaster I don't understand yes
you did
no this is the best okay come on you
gotta love Chris Wallace that is
fantastic stuff
owning owning Stephen Colbert right
there how you could see Stephen Colbert
feel the pain it goes directly to his
small heart it's just fantastic
yes Wallace just provided more comedy on
Colbert show than Colbert has provided
in years that was fantastic fan tastic
you know what play it again that was
great I got to watch it again well I
should watch the Stephen Colbert
collapses in on himself like a dying
star fantastic this has been a disaster
for the Democrats and a disaster for the
reputation of Robert Muller
now you said that at 10:07 this morning
an hour and a half into a six-hour
series of hearings so was Fox News motto
we report and decide before the things
over there was a break in the hearing
yes you were asked for our reaction and
let me simply say nothing in your
monologue disproved that description and
what way was it a disaster I don't
understand yes you do because of course
he does of course he does you couldn't
wash that thing yesterday without
understanding exactly what Chris Wallace
was saying good for Chris Wallace for
not taking that let me explain to you
like a small child why it was a disaster
you watched it
you knew and I loved I loved Stephen
Colbert's work in there well you didn't
wait until all the facts are in sir is
that really news II of you is that
really news yeah tell me about news
Stephen Colbert tell me that how news
should be done and if that's your best
excuse well you said it early you said
it early yeah did anything change no it
didn't good for Chris Wallace man that
is solid solid stuff we'll get to the
Democratic presidential candidates
reacting to this and of course saying
what they have to say which is impeach
him in just one second first let me tell
you about this new app that I have been
using to lose weight and feel better it
is fantastic it really is I've been
using a day after day now it's called
noon and it really is terrific because
when you want to get in shape it's not
just about exercising or eat
health it's about changing your daily
habits because you might think for
example you're eating healthy and you're
actually not you may be doing bad
estimates of your portions you may for
example think that your exercise is
burning more calories than it is and you
wonder why it is you're not losing the
weight you might think well you know if
I do it for a week and then I'm off for
a week isn't really that big a deal
what noon does is it systematizes your
habits it uses psychology really to help
guide you it provides you more
information on a daily basis about what
you can do to improve your health it
even provides people who provide you
real-time feedback gives you partners so
you can work with it is fantastic I
really enjoy it noon is a habit changing
solution it helps users learn to develop
a new relationship with food through
personalized courses it's based in
psychology and who teaches you why you
do the things you do and arms you with
the tools to break the bad habits and
replace them with better ones because if
you know why you're doing it
maybe you won't do it anymore you don't
have to change it all in one day small
steps make a big progress sign up for
your trial today at noon n oo m comm
slash repair in fact I just got this for
my parents yesterday NUMA comm slash
Shapiro n oval and comm slash appear o
to try that trial today start that trial
right now that's Noom comm slash up here
it's the last weight-loss program you'll
need it really is terrific okay we're
gonna get to these more democratic
response to Muller and then we have to
get to the Governor of Puerto Rico who
apparently is resigning I know don't pay
too much attention to Puerto Rico until
there's big news there's big news out of
Puerto Rico today we'll get to that
we'll get to all of it in just one
second I have to remind you next month
we're taking our backstage show on the
road for a special one-night only event
it's August 21st at the beautiful
Terrace Theatre in Long Beach California
me daily where God came cherami boring
Andrew clave and Michael moles will all
be there alive well I mean it'll be
unbelievable can you imagine your dreams
coming true right before your very eyes
we'll be talking politics pop culture
answering your questions from the
audience make them good tickets are on
sale right now at Daley wire.com slash a
backstage including our limited VIP
packages those guaranteed premium
seating photos and meet and greets with
each one of us a gift from me I've been
chopping for weeks for this thing you're
gonna love it and more so head on over
to Daley wire.com slash backstage get
your tickets today that's Daley wire.com
slash backstage get those tickets right
now it shall be epic it has been so
declared and so it shall be also go
subscribe over daily wire com all sorts
of goodies for you there 99 bucks a year
gets you this the very greatest
all beverage vessels you know it you've
heard me talk about it every day for
years at this point why have you not
taken me up on this offer $99 a year
gets you all the goodies behind the
paywall two additional hours of the show
a day part of the mailbag you know all
that you know I don't have to repeat it
and it gets you this particular beverage
vessel which is the greatest of all
beverage vessels in more importantly
helps you join the team and protect us
in the content that you love from the
nastiness of the left that seeks to the
platform and destroy all shows that it
cannot control go check us out at daily
wire.com we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so as I say for Democrats it's in for a
penny in for a pound so the media
invested in the narrative that Bob
Muller got him not true
I did not and then you've got people who
are members of the Intel community who
didn't like Trump and we're in a running
gun battle with Trump for years and they
want Trump out and so it's Robert Muller
he wasn't as bad as you thought guys was
he really that bad I mean like really
they they've all now become the stage
mother whose child bombs in the second
act this is what they become oh there's
my kid he's so cute he's out there oh
that wasn't that wasn't go that's uh
you're okay right like that wasn't that
bad that was the entire story of
yesterday and then you've got the
Democratic presidential candidates now
Kamala Harris and Elizabeth Warren will
not vote for impeachment cause it's
never coming up in the Senate it's never
even coming up in the house
they're never gonna have to stand there
and really fight for the impeachment of
President Trump because why would they
have to there in a Senate controlled by
Republicans it's dead on arrival but
they're gonna go out there and because
they're running against Trump they're
gonna claim that he is in peach' Bowl
that he should be impeached that he's
committed impeachable offenses here is
Camilla Harris yesterday suggesting
don't worry guys there are outlined
incidents of obstruction really I mean
it's good what we this is impeachable
stuff do you think khamel harris really
believes this do you think she believes
anything she says i think there's a
reason that she's regressed back to the
mean and as we'll see in a second joe
biden may be starting to find his sea
legs but Kamala Harris regressing back
to the mean in stylish fashion here she
is I am very clear that there are
outlined incidents of obstruction of
justice and no matter what this current
Attorney General and the present United
States try to say the American people
are smart enough to know what is and
what is not truth okay sure
go for it and then Elizabeth Warren does
the same thing we should impeach we
should impeach it is very weird these
presidential campaigns where everybody
appears on the same set one after
another it's kind of bizarre it's also
bizarre to me that people find Elizabeth
Warren charismatic she is deeply
uncharismatic as far as I am concerned
she doesn't she's not magnetic in any
way she sort of seems like she's
scolding you all the time I think Carmel
Harris is significantly more magnetic a
personality than Elizabeth Warren is and
just in terms of sheer political skill
people who judge hasn't both beat
although he's going nowhere in this race
here's Elizabeth Warren also calling for
impeachment we have to make clear no one
is above the law not even the President
of the United States it is time to bring
in Pietschmann charges against him in my
view some things are above politics and
one of them is our constitutional
responsibilities to do what is right and
the responsibility of the Congress of
the United States of America when a
president breaks the law is to bring
impeachment charges against that
president you know one of the things I'm
finding off-putting about Warren is that
if you actually Trent if you if you
could deep fake beta O'Rourke and
Elizabeth Warren they have the same
mannerisms they've got the same arm
motions they the same cadence it's kind
of fascinating in any case when she says
that she believes that some things are
above partisan politics that is false
Elizabeth Warren believes know things
are above arts and politics that is just
untrue so Democrats you want to run on
this all you but I don't think Americans
are interested in this in any real way
in fact I know Americans are not
interested in this cuz there's poll data
Americans want you to move on Americans
already believe what they're gonna
believe about Trump there is no great
takeaway from this it's not as though
this raised awareness about what Trump
is everybody sort of has an opinion on
it already I'll tell you what does
change minds his new information so no
new information has been provided for
with regard to president Trump however
every day there seems to be new
information about the leading lights of
the Democratic Party so to take an
example
Ilhan Omar who president Trump
desperately wants to run against he
wishes that Ilhan Omar or the Democratic
nominee but it's okay they're promoting
her anyway there is a a clip that has
been circulating from 2018 in which
representative ohon Omar declares that
Americans should be more fearful of
white men than jihadist terrorists and
that basically white men should be
racially profiled she was appearing with
Mehdi Hasan on al Jazeera Al Jazeera of
course the Qatari front Qatar is a
terrorist supporting government in any
case here here she is explaining I mean
if this is your Democratic Party this is
what Trump wants to run against you
heard him say it earlier he said this is
the party evil head Omar this is what he
wants to run against if Democrats want
to run on impeachment and try
runs on Ilhan Omar is the face of the
Democratic Party enjoy yourselves
Democrats is gonna be a long another
four years of Donald Trump here is Ilhan
Omar saying something silly a lot of
conservatives in particular would say
that the rise in Islamophobia is the
result not of hate but a fear a
legitimate fear they say of
quote/unquote jihadist terrorism whether
it's Fort Hood or San Bernardino or the
recent truck attack in New York what do
you say to them I would say our country
should be more fearful of white man
across our country because they are
actually causing most of the deaths
within this country we should be
profiling monitoring and and and
creating policies to fight the
radicalization of white men okay good
good luck with this pitch good luck with
this particular picture there are a
couple of problems in that pitch number
one if you go back to September 11th
there's no question that jihadis have
caused more deaths than white
supremacists terrorists all assume
that's what she means if she's talking
about sheer numbers of deaths then white
men certainly have not caused the sheer
majority of deaths in the United States
and she's talked about terrorism which
is giving her sort of the benefit of the
doubt but that's fine I think that's
probably accurate if she's talking about
white supremacist terrorism yes it has
caused deaths it is controversial as to
whether it has caused most of the deaths
in the United States because that's a
matter of classification very often the
classification systems take anybody who
is white and who commits a terrorist act
and then lumps them together as white
supremacist which is not fully accurate
but the point is taken that white
supremacist caused a lot of deaths I
mean I know because they've targeted me
right there they're really evil but as a
proportion of the US population white
supremacists compared to the white male
population of the United States is a
tiny tiny tiny tiny tiny fraction it's
certainly a much smaller fraction than
jihadists compared to for example the
broader Islamic population of the United
States now I don't think that you should
label all Muslims because some radical
Muslims are terrorists in the United
States I don't think it's an excuse for
labeling all Muslims but the point that
she's making that you should rip that's
what she should say right you should say
what I just said which is why would you
paint all Muslims with broad strokes
when it is a small minority of Muslims
who are being radicalized Islamophobia
is never justified it's an easy answer
instead she goes to we should profile
white men because they're the real
danger good luck with that message
Democrats
enjoy yourselves okay meanwhile in other
news the governor of Puerto Rico has
announced that he is going to resign his
name is Ricardo Rosello and his he is
resigning because he got caught up in a
scandal where a bunch of his text
messages to other members of his
government were revealed and they were
pretty ugly and they used all sorts of
nasty language about other members of
the government particularly at the local
level now the the Governor of Puerto
Rico is a Democrat he's been at war with
other members of the government who are
also Democrats also a member of his
members of his party he's been accused
of corruption before a couple members of
his administration were just indicted a
couple of weeks ago and so now he is
stepping down according to the New York
Times the people of Puerto Rico knew him
first as Ricky the handsome boy who
moved into the governor's residence when
he was just 13 his father was the
governor ricardo rosado grew up as a
child of privilege in historic LeFort
izella a palatial 16th century mansion
with heavy drapes and thick wooden doors
just steps from the Caribbean Sea now
the governor himself
Rossella lives in the same colonial
Fortress of his youth with a family of
his own
but the estate has turned into a cage
guarded by police officers in riot gear
and ringed by protesters who wants him
gone it took just 2 weeks for his
administration to reach the point of
collapse undermined by a popular
uprising that the governor initially
thought he could with skin yet Rossella
misread the anger brewing among his
people after years of economic
stagnation and broken promises well the
reason for the economic stagnation and
broken promises is because Puerto Rico's
economy has been incredibly weak they
have spent much more money than they
ever had according to CNN Puerto Rico
has about a 70 billion dollar debt about
40% of its residents live in poverty and
the median household income in 2017 was
just under $20,000 that's not the low
income households it's the median
household income in the United States
it's well above $50,000 part of the
problem stems from US law back in 1920
according to CNN the Jones Act requires
all goods ferried between the US ports
to be carried on ships built owned and
operated by Americans by the way I do
oppose the Jones Act but really what
this is about is the wild overspending
of the Puerto Rican government things
got really bad in 2015 when Puerto Rico
defaulted on its monthly debt for the
first time in 2017 Puerto Rico filed for
bankruptcy which is a vicious cycle
because as the economy gets worse more
Puerto Ricans leave the government has
less tax money so they end up trying to
raise taxes in order to grab money back
and pay things
or take austerity measures which are
unpopular this is what happens when you
get into an overspending cycle and then
there's the hurricane that hit the
island in 2017 killing somewhere between
3,000 and 5,000 people also wiping out
power for months there were serious
allegations of mishandling of that by
everybody from state to local
authorities the hurricane cost an
estimated ninety five billion dollars in
total damage and then meanwhile there
were people in row cellars
administration who were being indicted
for wasting taxpayer money on their
friends lavishing they're friends with
government contracts and then it turns
out that a couple of weeks ago about 900
pages of leaked chats from the
governor's private telegram messenger
group ended up on the Puerto Rico Center
for Investigative Journalism apparently
Rossella and 11 of his top aides and
cabinet members exchanged profanity
laced homophobic misogynistic messages
about fellow politicians now there's a
Trump angle to all of this which is that
many of the people who are attacking
Rossella are angry at him because they
felt that he was bending over backwards
to cater to Trump but what choice did he
have
his state is literally bankrupt Puerto
Rico is literally bankrupt they went
bankrupt in 2017 and when a disaster
hits he has to beg the United States for
help he has to beg the US federal
government for help and so what are you
rip on him because he's treating I mean
it's it's like Chris Christie treating
Barack Obama nicely except that chris
Christie didn't need to treat him nicely
to get what he wanted well Trump is the
kind of guy who needs a little bit of
flattering to get what he wants in one
message Puerto Rico's then chief Fiscal
Officer Christian Sabrina Vega wrote he
was salivating to shoot San Juan mayor
Carmen ulee's Cruz a frequent critic of
the governor and of President Trump the
governor responded you'd be doing me a
grand favor of course that's a joke and
everybody knows that's a joke
sabrina vega also made crude remarks
about a puerto rican pop star saying
nothing says patriarchal oppression like
ricky martin ricky martin is such a male
chauvinist that he bleeps men because
women don't measure up pure patriarchy
and of course this is this means
brutality and terribleness okay well all
of these people seem pretty terrible at
their jobs but this is one of the
consequences of a fiscal crisis the
reason this has broader relevance is not
merely because one of the reasons the
Puerto Rico is having trouble becoming a
United States right like being interned
there every year there's a proposal to
incorporate Puerto Rico into the United
States one of the problems is that means
the federal government would
have to inherit all of that debt but it
does raise the question of what happens
when this problem comes to the United
States and I'm in Puerto Rico I mean the
debt crisis because the fact is that
Puerto Rico declared bankruptcy on a
municipal level the United States is
running a twenty two trillion dollar
debt twenty two trillion dollars and
today President Trump endorsed another
two-year budget deal that blows out the
budget to the tune of a trillion dollars
in deficit for the next two years the
Republican Study Committee came out they
said this is a bad deal but Trump wants
to get past the election when you keep
kicking the can down the road you end up
with unworkable alternatives and
Democrats want to raise the spending
anyway so they don't care about the
national debt they don't care about the
fact that debt eventually ends where
Puerto Rico ended up in a place where
you now have to take austerity measures
and cut benefits to your citizens who
don't like it and then elect governments
that don't have the power to do anything
because I can't borrow any more because
they're bankrupt and then they have to
take on stereo measures and then they
don't like it and then it creates
enormous amounts of turmoil now we can
keep kicking the can down the road
federally Puerto Rico has not been able
to keep kicking the can down the road
and so now they're eating their own
again this is a democratic politician in
Puerto Rico who's being ousted by fellow
Democrats many of whom are further to
the left and it's just going to get
uglier over there so bad news for the
for the sitting governor of Puerto Rico
what he really should do at this point
where I him where I he if I if I were he
I would immediately release a yearbook
photo of myself in blackface because as
we know if you're a Democratic governor
and blackface then you survive any
scandal and we know that from Virginia
so it's about time for a card over to
Sela to do all of that over in Puerto
Rico but again the wages of debt our
political suicide that's that's where we
are going and as a country we ought to
heed the warning that we see in Puerto
Rico okay time for some things I like
and then some things that I hate so
things that I like today so Boris
Johnson has now taken over as Prime
Minister of Great Britain and he is
vowing that he is going to exit the EU
come rain or shine in October so either
there will be a deal or there'll be no
deal but if there's no deal brexit is
happening anyway it's pretty clear at
this point that Parliament doesn't
actually have the power to stop that
Teresa made didn't want brexit to happen
she wanted to avoid an Odile brexit
Johnson is coming in with a mandate for
no deal brexit so he's basically now got
a lot of
power this is what he said yesterday the
doubters the doom stirs the gloom stirs
they are going to get it wrong again the
people who bet against Britain are going
to lose their shirts but this willing to
restore trust in our democracy and we're
going to fulfill the repeated promises
of Parliament to the people and come out
of the EU on October the 31st no ifs or
buts okay well it's gonna be very
contentious for the next couple of
months swatch in question session with
the Prime Minister today and it's a lot
of shouting and a lot of yelling I will
say the Brits have that part right that
parts a lot more fun it's funny when the
United States began there's a lot of
question as to the decorum of the United
States how would you title the President
and John Adams had this long flowing
title he wanted for the presidency was
like his Excellency His Majesty the
presidents of the United States and
instead just became mr. president well
unfortunately we formalized the
presidency more than the Brits
formalized the prime ministership I
think that we could use a little less
formality at this point you know again
it lets off the steam other things that
I like today so environmental activists
decided that they were going to glue
themselves superglue themselves to US
Capitol walls in a call for action on
climate change now what exactly is that
action I talked at length yesterday on
my radio show about the fact that there
are not really a lot of great solutions
for climate change the fact is China and
India have no interest in really doing
serious work on climate change if you
are a third world country you're mostly
interested in making sure that your
citizens aren't dying of starvation and
that means the use of carbon-based fuels
there are no alternative energies that
are anywhere as close anywhere close to
his efficient as carbon-based fuels
cap-and-trade has been an enormous
failure in Europe there's talk about
carbon taxes that would just be it
wouldn't be a cap-and-trade system it
would just be a system of taxation on
each ton of carbon emissions and then
you do what you're going to do but again
that relies heavily on the development
of an alternative energy source that is
competitive with other countries in the
world and the real question becomes how
much are people willing to pay
additionally for energy in a political
arena where people feel their government
doesn't have their own interests at
heart
in any case it's much easier to go and
just clean that nobody cares about the
problem than to actually come up with
some practical solutions for it like for
example deregulating nuclear energy
yesterday a group of environmental
activists took a novel approach to
calling for congressional action on
climate change they superglued
themselves to the wall of a capital
tunnel some of the protesters were
draped in bright yellow police tape
others wearing placards reading due to
climate emergency Congress is shut down
until sufficient action is taken to
address the crisis a group of activists
had used gorilla glue to fasten their
hands to the door jams of a tunnel
connecting the Capitol Hill to the House
office buildings according to a
participant about 15 other people were
helping the video was posted online by
extinction rebellion a group that
organized the demonstration here is what
it sounded like people are just going
right underneath them so there they're
really not obstructing very much I mean
like super glue yourself there dude it's
not like you woke up and somebody had
super glued you to the wall and you put
yourself in this particular position
ow oh because can I tell you something
climate action on a global scale with
the help of China India and Russia
that's not gonna happen
just cuz you super glued yourself to a
window you're just super glued to a
window you're aware of that are you not
apparently not so useless ow
useless action that's definitely going
to get things done it was not
immediately clear according to the
Washington Post how the demonstrators
were removed from the Capitol walls and
whether anyone was injured in the
process one protester may have had her
hand ripped from the wall by an
unidentified person trying to get
through the doorway because people still
have jobs to do some members of the
group were carrying acetone solution
which can dissolve glue so at least they
came prepared to you know leave without
any further problems although the
protesters have tracted attention they
were less than successful in blocking
the Capitol passageways according to the
Washington Post staff members reporters
police officers and lawmakers could we
seen ducking under the activists
outstretched arms to make their way past
them if you respect the climate
emergency you will go around one of the
superglued protesters can be heard
saying in the video as a steady stream
of seemingly unfazed Capitol denizens
passed below his arm and through the
tunnel I guess not
another protester reply okay well
deserved well deserved so again stupid
protests are some of my favorite
protests whether it's PETA having
themselves branded like cattle to do
what just like now you now you have a
brand on you which is gross and weird or
whether it is people super gluing
themselves ala a Christmas story a
double dog dare that that's that's a
take right there it's it to move I'm not
gonna say it's a smart move I'm not
gonna say it's gonna achieve anything in
fact I'm gonna say the apps it's pretty
stupid and doesn't achieve anything and
everybody's kind of annoyed and we laugh
at you when people stretch our hands
skin that is connected to the window
that you put there yourself cuz you're
an idiot
how about this how about practical
action less moral posturing
unfortunately this has become when it
comes to climate change huge swathes to
the left just them sitting there and
screaming in agony about climate change
without anything remotely resembling a
proper solution well well done well done
protesters for proving once and for all
that you really have nothing to do here
except yell and scream and pretend that
you have ideas okay time for a quick
thing that I hate so honestly I don't
know whether to put this in things I
hate are things I love because this
story is just phenomenal so the cut has
a long piece today it's New York
Magazine a piece called the most
gullible man in Cambridge a harvard law
professor who teaches a class on
judgment wouldn't seem like an obvious
mark would he the pieces by Cara Bala
Nick what's wonderful about this is
social justice warrior sensibilities
coming back to eat alive a Harvard Law
Professor now I never took a class from
Bruce hey Bruce hey it was always
perceived as one of the more bizarre
professors at Harvard Law School he
proved himself so in this story this
story is both glorious and horrifying in
virtually every way quote it was just
supposed to have been a quick Saturday
morning errand to buy picture hooks on
March 7th 2015 Harvard Law Professor
Bruce hay than 52 was in tags hardware
in Cambridge Massachusetts near his home
when a young woman with long reddish
brown hair approached him to ask where
she could find Batteries it was still
very much winter and once the woman got
his attention he saw that underneath her
dark woolen coat and perfectly tied
scarf she was wearing a dress and a chic
pair of boots hardly typical weekend
errand attire in the New England
Collegetown when he directed her to
another part of the store she changed
the subject by the way you're very
attractive he remembers her saying okay
so first of all dudes note if you're out
at a hardware store and a hot lady comes
up to you and she just says to you
randomly by the way you're very
attractive
look for your wallet this is not going
to go well this has never happened in
real life this only happens in
apparently pornography movies so I have
been told apparently this professor did
not know this and so he immediately was
like I am attractive Wow sorry I'm
married he responded impulsively it
wasn't exactly true he has been legally
divorced since 1999 but he lives with
his ex-wife Jennifer Zacks an assistant
US attorney in Boston and their two
young children the woman quickly
apologized he recalls I didn't mean to
bother you she said I'm just tearing
business for a few days I don't really
know anybody okay at this point once
somebody says that like still the radars
not going up the wisest and brightest
and most elite among those brucei how
does that not send your antenna
spiraling right how how how's your
unscented nut up she starts with you're
very attractive and then she goes to I'm
alone in the city for a couple of days
hey really this is not how real life
works man hey a Francophile notice the
woman had a French sounding accent and
asked if she spoke the language she told
him her name was Maria Pia Schumann that
she was born in France but her father
was the American songwriter Mort Shuman
and that she was in town from Paris
enroute to New York Schumann gave hay
her email address the professor wasn't
accustomed to picking up women in random
places let alone getting picked up by
them that's because no man has ever been
picked up alone in a random place by a
woman maybe it's happened but it is a
rare occasion hey he was intrigued no
kidding
since moving back in with his ex-wife in
2004 he says the relationship and mostly
platonic and it's you had an
understanding that if either of them
wanted to see other people they'd have
to move out but casual flings he
believed fell under a tacit
don't-ask-don't-tell policy by email hey
in Schumann a register ranged have
coffee that afternoon where they bonded
over losing parents
to young she was now 32 an accountant
with young children hate hate old says
she told him she had two toddlers she
was co-parenting with an ex-wife who
lived in London file under friendship
hey thought rekha she's a lesbian
Schumann also told him about the friend
she was staying with Mischa Heder a
brilliant trans woman pursuing a
doctorate in physics at Harvard who was
struggling with
crippling depression hey who also
battled depression listen with
particular interest after a couple of
hours Schumann said I've really enjoyed
this but I have to leave town in a
couple of days I hope we can see each
other before then they went to dinner
that night and again the next at the end
of the second evening Schumann asked him
to join her for breakfast the following
morning I was smitten hey says I wasn't
sure what the Maria Pia thing was going
to be
that's the truthful answer because one
of the first things out of her mouth was
that she had just divorced a woman in
England he didn't mind that a physical
relationship was probably off the table
he was taking antidepressants which
often hampered his ability to enjoy sex
anyway then on the day Schumann told him
she was leaving from New York on her way
back to Europe a says she invited him to
a room at the Taj Hotel in Boston
started kissing him and led him to her
bed hey drove Schumann to the airport
early that evening so again at some
point you might find this story
suspicious right she picks you up in a
hardware store you have dinner a few
times she says she's a lesbian and now
she's having sex with you at some point
you might be like this is weird but not
if you're a Harvard man hey drove a few
months to the airport early that evening
for the next few weeks she traveled to
London in Paris she called and texted
him daily 102 calls that month according
to phone records a few times yes if she
would FaceTime or Skype with him she
refused and found her resistance strange
but he didn't press the issue by this
point she'd begun to clearing her love
for him she told me she never got
involved with men and I was this big
exception he says oh my goodness it
seems odd she would express such
feelings for him after a few days
together but while he dismissed her
intensity as a folly of youth there was
a part of him that entertained the
possibility she was serious why not be
open to it he wondered it had been years
since he'd felt such a profound
connection so if you can sense that this
story is going to go the wrong way this
was it this is correct a few weeks later
she texted to say she was returning to
Cambridge and wanted to see him they met
the next day at the Sheraton commander
and had sex almost as soon as it was
over Schumann's mood shifted she became
dour than angry telling him she couldn't
abide his keeping their relationship a
secret nor what she says
he says she referred to as his continued
attachment to Zacks she demanded he
leave her
he was confounded he wasn't about to
leave his partner of 28 years for a
woman he'd slept with twice he got up
dressed and left
later that day Schumann contacted him to
say she was open to discussing pursuing
a relationship when hey demure she told
him she didn't see any point in staying
in touch but they did stay in touch over
the next four years the LA
professor would be drawn into a campaign
of fraud extortion and false accusations
at one point his family would be left
suddenly homeless at another Owens what
his lawyer has described as the
weaponization of the university's title
mine machinery against a he would find
himself indefinitely suspended from his
job accrue over three hundred thousand
dollars in legal bills with no end to
litigation in sight
hey this is and this is where the story
be goes from the weirdly pornographic to
be merely politically delicious whether
Schumann knew it when she met him she'd
found the perfect mark in Bruce a an
authority on Civil Procedure who'd spent
much of his life in the ivory tower
though he leans left he briefly briefly
clerked for Antonin Scalia because so
gulia always had a left-leaning clerk he
could argue with hey joined the Harvard
Law faculty in 1992 a close friend calls
him the quintessential absent-minded
professor who tends to lose things
phones and laptops and to miss social
cues at friends he took his classes they
said he was pretty weird hey has a
tight-knit circle of friends many of
whom are women and though their
relationships are non-sexual the
intensity he tells me has been a
continual source of conflicts with
Zach's Jennifer sons says my women
friends have always had ulterior motives
my response has been that my best
friends have been women for my entire
life
he and Zach's first met at Harvard Law
in 1987 they married two years later
they had a son together before
separating then he moved back in and
they had two more children together okay
and then things got weird six weeks
after they broke off contact Schumann
called hey to tell him she was pregnant
with his baby she hadn't had sex with
another man in the past year she said he
was stunned he hadn't even ejaculated
during either of their encounters a side
effect of his medication but he
understood the pregnancy was possible if
rare without orgasm Schumann said she
was weighing whether to terminate the
pregnancy then quickly followed up by
saying she'd made the decision to
carried it her she was due in January he
says she didn't bring up money he was
more surprised when he learned that
Schumann would be relocating to
Cambridge that summer she told him in
June she had purchased a three-bedroom
mansard Victorian now valued at 1.9
million dollars on a side street in the
Radcliffe neighborhood less than a mile
from his house and had brought her
children over from London
Maria PMA at 10:00 as though she had
scarcely ever been to Cambridge she says
she says she didn't know the area very
well didn't really know anybody Schumann
explained she purchased the apartment as
an investment and as a place for Heder
that's her graduate student trans
woman friend to live while she finished
her grad work she and hater she told hey
had been best friends since they met as
physics students their first year at
Imperial College in London later in a
conversation that summer Schumann
revealed that she and hater were raising
the children together good lucks of
those kids man the unfolding revelations
did little to put off hey who says he
was determined to take full
responsibility for my actions
throughout the summer he and Schumann
got together once or twice and discussed
rekindling their romance but she told
him it was contingent on him telling
Sachs about the affair and the baby
which he wasn't willing to do they
hadn't been sexually involved since
there encountered the Sheridan commander
in April but Schumann could be effusive
okay to make a longer story short it
turns out this baby probably not his but
he wasn't willing to say so because he
thought hey she's a lesbian and it's
politically incorrect to see just maybe
she's had sex with other men hater the
trans woman often loomed large in their
conversations even as Schumann demanded
more of his time she was cagey about
letting him meet the woman she called
her soul sister when he asked about her
he says Schumann responded that hater
was depressed and wasn't up for meeting
new people finally they met Schumann had
told him that hater was weary of her
physics program and wanted to get more
involved in trans activism and write
about trans issues I thought maybe I
could help her calls hey
she'd been described to me as this very
exceptional person but downtrodden
treated unfairly by family and by the
world by her body by the time I met
Misha I had a protective feeling for her
their bond appeared instantaneous we had
similar political views he said she told
me a lot about the trans world I'd know
nothing about it soon they were getting
coffee almost daily talking for hours
sometimes meeting at a coffee shop near
Harvard hit her regularly texted and
emailed hey articles and stats about
trans women being brutalized and
murdered by men her communications were
often punctuated with a kind of fixated
anxiety about being persecuted for being
trans they believed he'd identified a
kindred spirit so he was sensitive to
her emotional state they confided in
each other about their depression and
suicidal thoughts he had been molested
as a teenager he told hater about the
experience he was struggling with
drinking he insists his friendship was
more familial than romantic a month
after their first coffee hater texted
hey to say I'm so happy we met they're
wonderful and stimulating company behind
his back though the women mocked a and a
text message to hater that they provided
Schumann refers to him as effing
desperado by then hater rarely saw
Schumer Schumann any more still they
began
discussing the possibility that hey
would move in with them so then the
family relationship would be hey Shuma
and a lesbian a trans woman and Bruce
Hey
he said his relationship with the women
could be intoxicating he said that they
were nearly perfect people who were
bright and kind and sweet and socially
conscious it turns out that um no so hey
used his publishing connections to help
aid her pursue her writing he tried to
get this person's this man that means a
biological man this person's writing
posted on the Guardian and The
Huffington Post hey accompanied hit her
to Phoenix to consult about gender
affirmation surgery in the spring on
January 14th 2016 hater called hey to
tell him that Schumann had given birth
to a baby boy hey it asked to be present
for the baby's birth but Schumann
refused hey ask to meet the newborn but
again Schumann refused the woman also
told hey because he'd failed to separate
from Zach saying listed haters name not
his as the other parents on the little
boy's birth certificate while he was in
Paris the woman's calls and texts
intensified taking on an increasingly
combative tone at one point hater told
hey she was gonna get euthanasia hey
meanwhile I actually become suspicious
and Zach's took all of this as an
enormous betrayal
Zach's told hey it was highly unlikely
he got Schumann pregnant Jennifer
suggested I was ignoring the evidence
because I wanted to believe the child
was mine perhaps she was right Zach's
pushed hated fraternity tests he
wouldn't have it here's the key not only
did he trust Schumann he felt it would
have been insulting for a heterosexual
cisgender man to question a professed
lesbian as to whether she had had sex
with other men he believed her when she
said her sexual relationship with him
was an exception hey met the baby for
the first time said I never doubted he
was my son Schumann told him she was
being treated for recurrence of cancer
again the diagnosis was fishy he began
to entertain doubts about the woman it
all got very weird obviously even
weirder throughout the summer the women
suggested that hey disentangle from
Zach's and then here's what ends up
happening because the story is really
long since the new yorker here's what
ends up happening it turns out that they
defraud him out of his house the women
returned to his house before Christmas
Zach's again called the cops they she
started calling
cops on them the next day the women sent
texts to hey calling him a rapist who
needed to be reported to authorities he
started receiving texts from an unknown
number you will not get away with rape
still he kept hanging out with them and
then they stopped by they asked him to
sign the documents he didn't read the
documents and he ended up signing over
the deed to his house they ended up
sending a he signed over the deed to his
house allegedly and not only that he
then got involved in a title nine
scandal because he was accused by these
women or by a woman and a trans trans
woman a sexual of sexual harassment and
he ended up losing his job okay it turns
out that when you blind yourself to
truths because you were trying to be too
politically incorrect there are some bad
effects of that things tend to get
rather hairy and awful that that Bruce
hey man you were blinded by blinded by
reality blinded by my goodness that is
that's some solid stuff is it not okay
we can't I think we can all acknowledge
at this point that if you get scammed by
a lesbian and a transgender woman into
giving up your home then you probably
shouldn't be teaching law at Harvard is
that fair is that fair you probably
shouldn't be teaching justice and law
you might not be like the best source
for students the summary according to
National Review is that hey says she
began making hysterical demands got him
to sign a sheaf of papers he didn't read
he said that she was a count since she
knew best and on a thin pretext gave him
a check for three thousand bucks which
he then cast cashed it turns out he had
signed over his 3.5 million dollar house
to her and her trans buddy for lease at
a nominal rate the check framed as a
security deposit the woman and trans
friend first moved to all the stuff out
of the house charged the expenses to his
credit card which he'd given them access
to his ex-wife saw a lot of this coming
and had arranged have the house put in
her name only so that made the lease
invalid but he incurred some $300,000
worth of legal bills and then the woman
who seduced him charged him with sexual
abuse and he was suspended automatically
under the title mine policy well Bruce
Hey
yeah sad story of Bruce hey right there
suffice it to say perhaps you should
examine the realities about you instead
of
falling prey to two of the oldest tricks
in the book trick number one you're a
very attractive man at a hardware store
trick number two here are me and all my
social social justice warrior friends
who want to be your best friends and
raise children with you and also you're
a rapist
so we parent we've been a fond farewell
to that story my goodness that's a wild
story we'll see you here later today for
two additional I've had some great
guests today on the program Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo is stopping by we will
also be having on representative Lee
Zeldin of the house to talk about the
Muller hearing yesterday so a lot of
good stuff coming up those subscribes he
can be part of it otherwise we'll see
you here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro you're
listening to the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Joshua
alvera production assistant Nick Sheehan
the Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily weiter 2019
if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right